standing at mount arafat is considered
the high point of the hajj ritual
the day before known as tarwya sees the
pilgrims gather at the mina valley to
prepare for the climb
arafat is where they will stand for most
of the day addressing the sky
with their personal prayers last year at
the first
hajj since the coronavirus pandemic
struck only
1 000 people were allowed to attend
this year there will be sixty thousand
all from within saudi arabia
in previous years there would be more
than two million from around the world
sure i was saying when i realized that
i'm one of only 60 000 people doing this
hajj and when i compare it to those who
did it with the messenger of god
peace be upon him being more numerous
they were about 100 000
i feel as part of a group who've been
privileged by being able to do this hard
ritual praise be to god
the fact that god the almighty has
chosen us from these millions to be able
to reach this holy site
we take it as a sign that god willing
our worship is accepted
and our prayers are answered
the contrast with how it looks now to a
few years ago is stuck
this was 2018 and this
now to this young man there was
something uncanny about the place
there's a sense of subkina of holy
silent luminous bliss up here
it's a bit cloudy up there and no one
around here
by god it's like i'm in a dream i don't
know how to describe it really
the saudi authorities took unprecedented
security and safety measures
that went beyond masks vaccines and
social distancing
the so-called unified security
operations 911 plan for the hajj of 2021
included a host of procedures adopted
for the first time
of course this year's pilgrimage is
completely different and exceptional
no pilgrim can access the holy site
except through the four reception
centers
assigned by the ministry also pilgrims
cannot enter any camp except through the
smart gate
those attending had to be aged between
18 and 65
vaccinated and free of chronic diseases
on tuesday which coincides with the day
of sacrifice
the pilgrims return to mecca and the
mini valley for three more days of
rituals
muhammad